messieurs bonjour merci d'être avec nous
ce matin pour revenir sur l'actualité de
ces dernières heures et pour commencer
on a appris hier soir que le réfugié
afghan arrivé en france récemment été
condamné à dix mois de prison avec
sursis il a violé la mesure de contrôle
administratif à laquelle il était soumis
la france par ailleurs un kia qui a des
doutes 1 concernant ses liens avec les
talibans au vu de ses doutes au vu de la
situation la réponse judiciaire est ce
que c'est la bonne selon vous thomas
porte on va commencer avec vous
mais vous avez rappelé les faits c'est à
dire qu'il ya eu une présentation sur
des liens avec les talibans une rupture
de son contrôle les services secret les
services de sécurité français avaient
identifié ce fait-là et l'ont placé sous
surveillance et l'ont ils l'ont arrêté
donc la réponse judiciaire et la réponse
policière elle a été à la hauteur
simplement aujourd'hui on assiste à une
espèce de
d'instrumentalisation de ce qui s'est
passé pour assimiler tous les réfugiés
afghans doivent accueillir regarder la
situation problématique du pays à des
terroristes c'est ce qu'avait dit
quelques jours d'ailleurs christian
estrosi où il avait dit je refuse
d'accueillir puisqu'il ya des
terroristes potentiels donc aujourd'hui
on a le devoir d'accueillir et je le
redis ici celles et ceux qui sont en
afghanistan qui ont lutté pour les
libertés à leur pays on pense aux femmes
aux enfants et il ya aussi des hommes
parce qu'on dit qu'il ya beaucoup
d'hommes qui arrivent mais a beaucoup
dans qui ont mené le combat là bas qui
ont travaillé avec les services français
on a eu hier un chiffre par exemple dans
libération qui dit qu'il ya les
auxiliaires qui travaillent avec l'armée
française sur 200 il ya à peu près une
quinzaine qui ont simplement été
rapatriés donc aujourd'hui la france
elle a un devoir inconditionnels
d'accueil avec l'europe tout le monde
doit prendre sa part parce qu'on a un
pays qui aujourd'hui soumis à
l'obscurantisme religieux avec les
talibans il faut accueillir celles et
ceux qui sont menacés de mort parce que
c'est ça la réalité en fait gilbert
collard finalement bien en tant que
thomas porte qui nous dit qu'il faut pas
faire une généralité tous les avions qui
arrivent ne sont pas des terroristes
cette condamnation à dix mois de prison
c'est la bonne réponse aussi selon vous
la bonne réponse c'est qu'on n'est pas
sur le territoire des individus qui
constitue une menace alors cessé
c'est vrai que l'on ne peut pas poser
une généralisation ni dans un sens ni
dans 90 parce que c'est au cip est dans
un sens que dans un autre mais le drian
se féliciter d'avoir pu faire entrer sur
le territoire et non pas rapatrier
puisqu'on est rapatrié quand on retourne
dans sa patrie donc il faut que les mots
et un sens donc ccc faire venir en
france au delà de 1000 personnes en une
semaine moi la question que je me pose
c'est comment ont-ils pu opérer en une
semaine sur les 2000 personnes qu'ils
ont ramené en france des contrôles de
sécurité nécessaires qui seront par
exemple que monsieur porte et ça je le
souhaite de tout mon coeur ne soit pas
agresser par un parent terroristes qui
se sera mêlé au flot des réfugiés comme
des choux l'avait nous l'avait promis
voilà il s'agit je crois de penser
d'abord à nos compatriotes à leur
sécurité et ensuite dans la mesure où on
peut exercer des contrôles efficaces
faire en sorte qu'on récupère celles et
ceux qui méritent de l'être c'est-à-dire
qui juridiquement répondent aux
conditions légales du droit d'asile je
veux dire que là il s'agit pas de faire
d'angélisme je crois que si on fait de
la politique avec cette question l'un
dans un sens ou dans un autre on peut
faire du tort d'abord à celles et à ceux
qui sont potentiellement en droit je dis
bien en droit avec toutes les garanties
nécessaires d'être acceptée et à celles
et ceux qui vivent sur le territoire qui
n'ont pas envie parce qu'un seul
terroriste de faire des dégâts
monumentaux horrible d'être victime
d'une action terroriste et donc il faut
d'abord et avant tout récupérer
les afghans et les afghanes qui ont
servi la france
200 personnes à peu près ça on les
connaît ils sont répertoriés et sont
fichés d'entre eux n'a pas de mal à les
localiser cela bien évidemment il n'est
pas question de les laisser aux mains de
c2c de ces barbares terroristes mais
pour les autres il n'y a pas de pétition
de principe ya des contrôles a fait en
fonction des garanties qu'on peut avoir
on doit s'il relève du risque réel d'une
menace terroriste
les héberger mais sinon on n'a pas de
raison de le faire systématiquement le
systématisme cela peut servir de de
moyens au terrorisme pour renforcer sa
position activités dangereuses dans le
pays donc je crois pour doit faire
preuve d'un réel pragmatisme et
l'incident des cinq qui ont été repérés
qui sont maintenant surveiller nous
montre que ce que l'otan nous annoncé il
ya maintenant des ya maintenant trois
ans je crois à savoir que des chutes il
aiderait des migrants pour implanter le
terrorisme c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est l'otan un essai dès qu'ils avaient
dit aussi à l'époque bon peut être une
réalité on doit en prendre compte pour
la sécurité alors concernant la sécurité
on va vous entendre tout de suite tu
m'apportes mais avant cette proposition
qui a qui a d'ailleurs fait assez
réagira notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux de sandrine de rousseau dont
vous êtes le porte parole regardez ces
paroles et puis vous nous expliquer
ensuite
si vraiment il ya des personnes qui sont
dangereuses des potentiels terroristes
ce n'est pas parce qu'ils restent en
afghanistan qu'ils sont moins dangereux
en vrai quelque part les avoirs en
france cela nous permet aussi de les
surveiller
alors thomas porte est-ce que vous vous
pouvez nous préciser la pensée de
sandrine rousseau effectivement c'est ce
que vous défendez aussi les avoirs en
france ça permet de les surveiller
non déjà cette phrase elle a été
extraite d'une vidéo de 2002 d'une
interview qui a été radié sur bfm tv ce
que dit sandrine rousseau c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui c'est pas parce qu'on a
fermé les frontières et c'est pas parce
qu'on a empêché les gens de devenir par
des moyens légaux que les terroristes
sont bas rhin pays
aujourd'hui on a ce qu'on dit c'est
qu'on n'a pas le droit de refuser
l'accueil des gens sous le prétexte
qu'il y aurait parmi eux des potentiels
terroristes et d'ailleurs je redis les
cinq qui ont été suspectés de terrorisme
est de lier avec les talibans ont été
arrêtés et ont été
on subit une peine à une sanction
judiciaire donc aujourd'hui on peut pas
trier les gens comme ça sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport et on a un devoir c'est pas
question de faire un systématisme c'est
aujourd'hui on a un devoir d'accueil où
il ya des milliers de gens et pas
simplement les 200 personnes qui ont
travaillé avec l'armée française on a
des gens qui travaillent dans des
commerces on a des gens qui travaillent
et qui ont monté des entreprises qui
travaillaient sur des projets par
exemple de mode avec des femmes et qui
est aujourd'hui menacée de mort nous
avons le devoir aujourd'hui de les
accueillir et la rhétorique du président
de la république quand il parle de flux
le flux sont les marchandises et
aujourd'hui on est calme face à des
êtres humains on est face à des femmes
des enfants et des hommes qui sont
menacées de mort dans un pays qui est en
guerre et on le sait et d'ailleurs c'est
aujourd'hui la situation dans laquelle
on est c'est parce que le gouvernement
français comme les gouvernements
européens n'ont pas anticipé ce qui
allait se passer puisque on savait que
dès le retrait de l'armée américaine
qu'il y allait avoir la chute du régime
puisqu'il ya c'était une armée fantoche
qui avait là bas on sait très bien on
l'a vu avec de la corruption et tout ce
qu'ils avaient avec donc aujourd'hui ce
qu'on dit c'est que il faut pas
instrumentaliser il faut pas faire de
généralités et que nous avons le devoir
d'accueillir ces personnes là qui sont
menacés de mort c'est l'honneur de la
france on a toujours accueilli ces gens
là et c'est pas simplement la france qui
doit les accueillir c'est l'europe mais
je le dis quand même que le canada parle
2000 personnes à accueillir le royaume
uni 20 milles on a quand même notre part
à prendre là dedans c'est notre adn
c'est notre histoire et il faut
accueillir ces gens là c'est ça les
propos qu'a dit rené rousseau et ils ont
été sortis de leur contexte et
instrumentalisé par une partie de la
droite et l'extrême droite mais nous
avons l'habitude de ce genre de
polémique gilbert collard est ce que
vous dénoncez vous aussi le manque
d'anticipation du quai d'orsay
finalement avant la prise de pouvoir
officielle par les talibans je suis
content que monsieur porte et employés
ce matin trois mots c'est bien bravo
honneur ça vous fait honneur de parler
d'honneur c'est bien
adn historique et histoire bravo c'est
bien c'est bien là ce sont trois mots
sur lesquels on s'entendra parfaitement
l'honneur l'histoire et notre adn vous
avez pas dit mais ça peut sortir en
titre
le devoir que nous avons il est d'abord
et avant tout de protéger les françaises
et les français et celles et ceux qui
n'étant ni français ni français sont sur
le territoire or on sait de source
empoisonné est sûr que
l'afghanistan est devenu maintenant un
pays un état terroriste
le choix était simple il ya ceux qui se
gargarisent au gargarisme morale en
ayant la belle figure des gens des gens
qui sont bons du matin au soir et puis à
ceux moins bon - gentil voilà
critiquable qui disent attention il faut
être très prudent et on ne peut pas
accueillir tout le monde parce que tout
le monde sait aussi des terroristes mais
ça veut pas dire fin de mon point de vue
un que l'on doit absolument rejeté tout
le monde de la même manière il faut ce
n'est pas parce que quelqu'un a ouvert
un commerce à kaboul que il est habilité
à être considéré comme bénéficiant du
droit d'asile d'autant plus qu'on sait
ce dont sont capables les talibans la
rouerie dont ils peuvent faire preuve et
on doit pour la protection des uns et
des autres c'est notre honneur là aussi
faire en sorte qu' il ne nous il ne nous
fasse pas venir des terroristes voilà en
ce qui concerne la manière dont tout
cela a été géré
le premier responsable c'est bien
évidemment biden 1 on a parlé à 100 ha
ha sont à 100 à son sujet de deux
stratégies landes retarder sa seat ça a
été fait à l'américaine bois en se
foutant de pas mal des dégâts humains
dans une impréparation totale des armes
ont été laissés sur place et quand même
incroyable bon et alors que la position
stratégique dominante militaire
qu'avaient les états unis leur aurait
permis d'organiser quand même un départ
beaucoup mieux structuré et beaucoup
plus sécurisée l'europe n'a rien fait de
mieux on est aux abonnés absents quand
je veux dire et pourtant on donne de
l'argent là-dedans distant de 600
millions d'euros sauf erreur de ma part
par ambre et la france dont la france on
a le drian un peu à un peu hagard un
kiki qui se contente de dire on a
récupéré deux mille personnes en une
semaine mais mais rien n'a été préparé
alors qu'on savait que ça allait arriver
bon donc il y a véritablement une
situation qui va être grave de
conséquences parce que les mesures
anticipatrice possibles n'ont pas été
prises et là y'a là il ya aussi du point
de vue de l'honneur des comptes à rendre
bien évidemment à propos de l'honneur
vous avez employé le mot tous les deux
pour l'honneur de la france eric ciotti
et plusieurs députés de droite ont écrit
au président emmanuel macron et pour eux
ils demandent que la france soutienne la
résistance sur place du fils du
commandant massoud avec notamment le
déploiement d'armes et de munitions pour
les evs et thomas porte est-ce que vous
soutenez cette initiative est ce que la
france doit aider la la poche de
résistance aux talibans ou en
afghanistan pardon
la france a une responsabilité
évidemment est de tout temps elle a aidé
celles et ceux qui menaient les
batailles contre le régime obscurantiste
et contre les dictatures aux quatre
coins de la planète maintenant vous
savez les chèques de l'afghanistan c'est
aussi le modèle impérialistes puis des
années c'est-à-dire exporter des guerres
et penser que nous allons mettre en
place le concept de démocratie en
apportant des militaires des armes et de
l'argent sans travailler avec les
populations locales et sert les associés
au processus démocratique et à la
prendre sur elle après la construction
du pays c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui partout on
a mené des guerres dites préventives ou
des guerres de riposte on a derrière les
cdp dans des étapes so lu ment
catastrophique et partout ça s'est passé
ça s'est très mal terminée donc il faut
revoir tout ça et quand je parle
d'accueil c'est aussi accueillir toutes
celles et ceux qui ont mené le combat
sur place pour les aider allen a en
france à reconstruire une forme de
résister c'est nos positions pour
reconquérir le pays derrière il ya aussi
sakho en jeu comment on accompagne ces
personnes qui pendant des années ont
mené un travail formidable sur le
terrain mais comment aujourd'hui on leur
permet de continuer à mener cette
bataille sans être exposé à la mort
parce qu'on sait qu'il ya des gens si on
ne les accueille pas dans le pays si on
les renvoie là bas ce sera synonyme de
mort assurée c'est ça qui va se passer
aujourd'hui quand on parle de l'accueil
des avions en harmonie gilbert collard
avant de revenir sur la situation
économique de la france vous vous
soutenez cette initiative d'eric ciotti
d'eric ciotti et des députés
républicains ont c'est de la com
je suis fatigué de ces gens d'ici qui
joue au lance-pierre avec des mots quoi
bon d'abord une observation si vous
permettez
là on est parent n'est pas au sens
léniniste donne d'une guerre de modèles
impérialistes c'est une sécu c'est une
erreur en excuses de vous le dire
rappelez-vous que que bush a ordonné
l'occupation américaine de l'afghanistan
à la suite de l'attentât contre les
tours à dire que ce impérialiste ou pas
faut faut être sérieux dans
l'analyse historico politique alors
c'est vrai qu'il a eu la volonté bien
des fois de transporter les modèles
impérialistes ça c'est vrai mais là on
peut pas dire que c'est le cas la russie
peut-être at-elle occupé l'afghanistan à
un moment donné pour implanter un modèle
politique peut-elle mais les américains
après coup après coup oui ils ont
peut-être cherché à imposer mais dans
une configuration militaires aux six
aussi stricte et dans une économie aussi
tribales je vois pas franchement sauf
erreur de vision historique de ma part
comment on peut imposer un modèle
impérialistes massoud maintenant
d'abord ce n'est pas en accueillant les
résistants ici qui résisteront la main
je sais pas mais ça me paraît ça me
paraît une évidence ensuite à soutenir
massoud je crois qu'on devrait avoir
l'intelligence mais là on se prive d'un
un lustrage du nombril politique on
devrait avoir l'intelligence ne pas le
dire et de le faire d'une manière plus
intelligente plus habile
c'est à l'instant on veut assurer la
protection des populations civiles c'est
pas forcément de bonne intelligence
politique que d'aller dire pendant qu'on
est en période d'évacuation on va
soutenir la résistance aux talibans pour
le fass oui mais dans des conditions
beaucoup plus diplomatique et
intelligente et que ce soit une
résistance globale on va pas désigné
maintenant un chef à la résistance parce
que là aussi dans la résistance en
afghanistan pour qui connaît bien le
pays et l'histoire ce qui est un peu
modestement mon cas on a quand même
encore une forme réelle de tribalisme
qui jouent et massoud pour toute
l'estimé que j'ai pour lui le respect
que j'ai pour lui
n'est pas n'est pas forcément le seul
derrière lequel les résistances
rangeront donc il va y avoir là aussi
des équilibres délicats à faire dans un
pays qui est vraiment constamment
situation de 2,2 déquilibre compte tenu
des rapports de forces entre les
différentes entre les différentes tribus
séance et entendu gilbert collard il
nous reste que quelques minutes
peut-être revenir sur cette annonce hier
du ministre de l'économie et des
finances je vais reprendre ses mots
maintenant que l'économie française
redémarre que nous avons des
perspectives de croissance à 6 % je le
dis le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est fini
les aides aux entreprises ce sera
désormais au cas par cas est ce que
c'est le bon moment pour vous de ma
porte
vous savez il suffit d'aller faire le
tour de toutes les entreprises qui ont
fermé pendant la crise pour demander aux
salariés si si le quoi qu'il en coûte a
vraiment été utile
j'ai entendu les appels de bruno le
maire qui notamment a exhorté les
patrons augmenter les salaires on se
rappelle que pendant la coved il avait
déjà appelé les patrons ne pas verser de
dividende en c'est l'effet que ça eu
c'est quand même surprenant de la part
d'un gouvernement qui se refuse
d'augmenter le smic par exemple depuis
2010 16 ou au va avoir dans la période
rêvée des chiffres très récents qui sont
sortis ou les 40 patrons les plus riches
de france donc toucher 5,3 millions
d'euros de salaire en 2021 soit une
hausse de 40% alors qu'on a qu'un des
salariés qui sont dans une difficulté
absolue on a aujourd'hui
des salariés qui sont menacés de
licenciement en raison de l'application
du pas sony terre et ça va arriver très
rapidement donc la rhétorique du
gouvernement elle est toujours à
destination des mêmes des grands groupes
et ls sur le côté des millions de
salariés des millions de petites
entreprises de tve de pme qui ont
souffert de la crise et qui vont avoir
énormément de mal à se relever
aujourd'hui gilbert collard est-ce que
vous partager l'optimisme du
gouvernement ce qui concerne la
situation économique
du monde
franchement bon pour et faisons toujours
un colloque politique mais le seul
monsieur le seul mot qui résume tous et
c'est la seule phrase aussi arrêtez de
vous de nous quoi bon quand on
voit la situation économique autour de
soi des as et pas les grands c'est pas
des gros jeux sur un cela surtout quand
ils travaillent dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique
tiens si au passage on est taxé un peu
plus là un pour redistribuer ne croyez
pas que ce serait une bonne chose mais
on n'en parle pas ça les brevets pas
question qu'ils soient publics les
entreprises pharmaceutiques
qui font des bénéfices colossaux sur sur
la maladie sur la souffrance sur la peur
même congénères bon vous croyez qu'on va
aller les taxer un peu plus ce serait
une bonne idée peut-être
pardon mais sur la question des levés
sur la question d'élever des brevets et
voilà ça fait des mois qu'on le demande
et sur la question des profits du big
pharma qui sont des profiteurs de crise
qui qui sort sur la pandémie pour en
faire une source de profit c'est
évidemment inacceptable
en tout cas sur le plan sanitaire c'est
l'arrivée de la troisième dose un pour
les plus de 65 ans l'om est ce qui
demande un moratoire qui rappelle que
les les pays les plus pauvres n'ont pas
accès aux vaccins est-ce que selon vous
gilbert collard on aurait pu attendre la
mise en place de cette troisième dose en
france dès septembre
nommé charité ou
s'arrêter ou c'est bien bien bien sombre
bientôt les religions doit être addict
aux vaccins troisième dose quatrième
dose ça va s'arrêter ou
moi je rappelle tout simplement qu' on
est encore en phase expérimentale
on est à l'affût dans la phase numéro 3
ou 4 et on est encore dans le cadre de
la conditionnalité
des vaccins c'est à dire que pour pour
modern art sera en 2022 que le vaccin
sera définitivement tester et pour les
autres c'est la même période à quelque
chose de prêt bon donc cette cette
espèce de de précipitations est
inquiétante et moi je m'excuse devant
j'ai peut-être tort mais je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de mettre tout ça en lien
avec la colossale industrie
pharmaceutique voilà je là où il ya des
gros bénéfices je m'inquiète voilà par
principe un je suis dès l'instant où les
marchands de canon on gagne beaucoup
d'argent dans une guerre je me demande
s'ils cherchent pas la guerre de ma
porte ce sera le mot de la fin
non mais on est on a des véritables
interrogations sur la troisième dose
puisque déjà on voit qu'après deux doses
et 90 95 % des formes graves du de la
maladie qui disparaissent en est
quasiment 60% de chances de ne pas être
contaminé est le véritable problème
c'est que on a déjà beaucoup de
personnes dans les pays riches qui ont
deux doses et on a des pays aujourd'hui
pauvres qui n'ont pas accès aux vaccins
qu'ils n'ont même pas la première dose
et on sait que c'est une pandémie
mondiale et si on va arrêter les
variants par exemple qui se développe
dans d'autres pays vaccinent sommes déjà
majoritairement les populations qui
n'ont même pas accès aujourd'hui la
première dose mais simplement
l'industrie pharmaceutique elle vend à
prix d'or ces doses donc elle va aux
pays qui ont de l'argent elle fait du
profit sur ça et c'est pas une réponse
politique sanitaire c'est aujourd'hui
une réponse financière et une course à
la recherche au profit qui n'est pas de
nature réponse aux enjeux de santé
publique un grand merci à tous les deux
en tout cas d'avoir échangé sur
l'actualité de ces dernières heures ce
matin sur rtl france merci à vous thomas
porte porte parole de la candidate à la
primaire écologiste sandrine rousseau
membre de génération point presse merci
à vous gilbert collard député européen
du rassemblement national